a family of seven killed in a mass
casualty crash on cheyenne and commerce
last month were laid to rest today at
palm west mortuary mary jane belliesa
joins us in the newsroom tonight with
how the community is really remembering
this family mary jane
sasha it was definitely packed there
today those i spoke to who knew the
family say the turnout speaks volume on
the impact of this tragedy
it's been three weeks since the deadly
crash that killed erlinda zakaria's four
children two step children and brother
now friends and family sharing an
emotional day to pay their respects and
say a final goodbye to the family of
seven in a private funeral ceremony
adriana signs says her heart goes out to
the mother erlinda as she has four kids
of her own i feel this this
the pain you know because i can imagine
things
happen like that only for people who are
driving crazy
it's like sad but at the same time is is
is wonderful how how the community you
know helped them osma fries describes
his favorite memories with fernando i'm
trying to play tech for him
and he likes to play tag but he want to
play high sick a family friend who
wanted to remain unidentified says his
kids and the family grew up together
thanksgiving we were together then we
were hiking together
so these kids i i knew them it is very
sad
what happened but
i hope
what happened
we can do something about it he believes
stricter laws should be in place for
speeding drivers saying no one should
feel the pain of losing their loved ones
to something so preventable if they get
somebody driving over a hundred miles on
an hour on the street they should go to
jail
don't matter if they got power if they
got money or they got lawyers or
whatever they should put them in jail at
least a month and if they do that i
believe that's going to stop some of
these people doing that
those i spoke with at the funeral say
they're thankful and appreciative at the
outpouring support from the community
reporting from the newsroom mary jane
boleyeza live local now